[Music]
today's question comes from james in
wyoming he says i'm 28 years old and i'm
on baby step 3. i'm looking ahead to
baby step 4 where my fiance and i will
invest 15 percent of our income into
retirement what are your thoughts on
dividend investing i was thinking after
the house has paid off the only thing
better than no payments is having
passive income from our investments
covering our living expenses i want to
achieve this before the age of 60 when
we can start withdrawing from our
retirement is this a good way to
allocate our 15
and if so how does receiving a dividend
work with a roth ira is it still taxed
great questions from a 28 year old i'm
impressed oh very good very good well a
dividend paying investment would be a
typically what's called a blue chip
company a large company
okay like a general motors okay
they're not usually very exciting in
their price changes
up or down
but they make a lot of money and so when
they make money and when you own a share
of stock you're one of the owners of the
company
you own a tiny little piece of the
company when you own one share of
general motor stock if they make a
profit and they decide to distribute
that profit to the owners that's called
a dividend
and so a dividend paying investment
would typically be large company stocks
that are paying out their profits
and are fairly predictable on that and
people buy them for that and that only
uh if that's in a roth ira the dividends
stay inside the roth ira until you're 59
and a half it's tax-free like anything
else is
but
and what you would do is flip the
dividends and they reinvest back into
more stock is what happens inside of
that you cannot pull anything out of a
roth ira before 59 and a half without
getting penalized and taxed
and so we're not going to use that for
something to get to early and i really
wouldn't do it um i just i if you if you
want to invest
i would just do 15 of your income into
the four types of mutual funds we talk
about growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international if
that gets too big and you're getting
close to 50 years old and you don't have
any money to support you between 55 and
60 or 50 55 and 59 and a half then you
might just start with something like
some index funds and that's called
bridge investing at that point which is
a taxable brokerage account where you
just invest and it's all it's going to
be taxed when you take it out but that
tax it's a taxable mutual fund yeah
that's what it is so with your roth ira
just leave it in there it'll be
reinvested it'll still help your money
grow but i wouldn't worry about this as
a passive income strategy yeah you've
been you've been reading too many
websites passive income is great when
you're in retirement and you get the
passive income from that investment from
that roth ira and it's a tax-free income
you don't need passive income
um uh and so
and typically these are the the calmest
of the four types okay the growth growth
and income it's a growth in income type
stock that would be a dividend and
income part
and that that's a those blue chip big
dinosaur companies and it's the least
exciting
the least uh rate of return it's the
lowest rate of return of the four types
we talk about and that i owe so i'm 61 i
did none of what you're talking about
all i did was
buy real estate that i pay cash for and
invest in those four types of mutual
funds in my 401 k that's and really
that's really all you need to do if you
you know up to
tens of millions i mean you don't need
to get fancy it's won't make you a
billionaire but uh but you won't be
broke and you'll be a millionaire and a
multi-millionaire you'll end up
somewhere in between
absolutely